Saffron,
beluga caviar,
truffles,
and Bonnotte potatoes
are just some of the world's
most expensive foods.
Wait, potatoes?
Is that right?
Guys, it says here on
the script "potatoes."
A Potato?
Seriously?
Welcome to Noirmoutier.
A tiny island off the
Atlantic coast of France.
This is the only place you
can find the king of potatoes.
His majesty, La Bonnotte.
But if you want to eat them
fresh you've got to be quick
as they're only available
for 10 days a year.
This is Rudy.
He's a potato farmer.
So what makes the island of Normoutier
so special for these spuds?
All the farmers on the island
are part of cooperative.
They deal with treating,
cleaning, selling,
and sending all over Europe.
Nicholas is the director.
He makes sure everything runs smoothly.
He really loves these potatoes.
Sorry.
Now, I hope you're sitting
down because in 1996
these pricey potatoes fetch
at auction an insane amount.
Drumroll!
Roughly $500 per pound.
Luckily, for you and me,
nowadays, Bonnotte potatoes
aren't going to break the bank.
Fetching more like 5 dollars per pound,
which is still a lot
for a bag of potatoes.
Once the harvest is complete
an annual Bonnotte festival is held.
Here, the golden potatoes
are traditionally served
with grilled sardines.
So how do they taste?
So there we have it.
The king of potatoes.
Thank you, Your Majesty.